who's the guy that's peeking out behind
the trash can vigilante's trying to be
helpful what i'm just looking for behind
the trash can it's a normal thing to do
the hell it is
my name is freddy stroma and i play
vigilante
doesn't really fit in with the group
he's the annoying friend who just stayed
around long enough peacemaker uh it's a
bff vigilante vigilante wants to be best
friends with peacemaker and he's not on
board with it for a long time dude i'm
your best friend
who's your best friend then it's eagley
good boy they start to really work
together i agree with peacemaker we
can't go in they're unprepared
no you're not taking that in there oh
i'm never gonna kill someone with a
chainsaw peacemaker has this realization
that like hey vigilante might be the
only guy who has my back
we have huge fight sequences where
they're both taking out bad guys
my boy peacemaker is sick
vigilante is definitely different here's
your answer
because shut up
please just use a gun like a normal
person
[Music]
you